blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman ground news is combating
divisiveness in media ground is a news
comparison platform that helps you see
multiple perspectives for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader download the free app at
ground dot news slash pacman so the
so-called investigations into voter
fraud are continuing the so-called audit
in arizona
is still going on the one where they're
looking for bamboo fibers or chili sauce
droplets or leftover
apple peels or whatever it is that
they're looking for that's continuing
but there is one voter fraud
investigation which has concluded and
that's been taking place in michigan and
we're going to look at the results this
was importantly a republican
investigation a republican investigation
finds no michigan vote fraud
and deems many claims ludicrous now this
is not
exclusively all logical from the
michigan republicans i will get to that
momentarily but the report uh out of
lansing says a months-long republican
investigation into michigan's 2020
election uncovered no evidence of
widespread fraud and concluded wednesday
with a recommendation the attorney
general investigate those who made the
claims for personal gain
the 35-page report
dives deep to debunk conspiracy theories
perpetuated by former president trump
and some of his supporters
remember that in michigan biden won by
about 155 000 votes well the senate
oversight committee investigation
revealed some glaring issues and
vulnerabilities the legislature should
fix quote there is no evidence presented
at this time to prove either significant
acts of fraud or that an organized wide
scale effort to commit fraudulent
activity was perpetrated in order to
subvert the will of michigan voters our
clear finding is that citizens should be
confident the results represent the true
results of the ballots cast by the
people of michigan the committee
strongly recommends citizens use a
critical eye and ear toward those who
have pushed demonstrably false theories
for their own personal gain
the report concludes there is no proof
of dead voters or fractional voting no
evidence of a fraudulent ballot dump in
detroit and no proof any michigan
precincts had more than 100 voter
turnout that's another claim that donald
trump made so this is all well and good
and it's a great thing except that
except that
some of the
things that are being recommended by
republicans
are still suppressive techniques that
aren't actually necessary given the
absence of fraud so let's kind of go
through this in two parts
if there's one thing that should give us
a little bit of reassurance from 2020
it's that in a sense the legal system
still worked in that it didn't allow
dozens and dozens of bogus lawsuits or
the supreme court as trump wanted to
flip the results of even a single state
never mind the election
you had more than 80 of these alleged uh
fraud cases brought forward in different
jurisdictions
and courts demanded evidence
um
the
completely unreliable and sometimes
potentially
uh so-called eyewitnesses were not
enough in just presenting conspiracy
theories about what they think they saw
or how many sandwiches there were in a
van that showed up late at night in
michigan or wherever it was the
conjecture the lies the courts did not
allow that to push forward these bogus
cases and more than 80 of these cases
were thrown out all across the country
in some situations the the trump legal
team
which was this motley crew of sometimes
rudy giuliani when he didn't have covid
jenna ellis
i guess sydney powell was part of it
although then when she was humiliating
herself trump said she was whatever
sometimes they were even laughed out of
court okay so that's good it's good that
at least there was this backstop where
even some trump appointed judges said
there's nothing here we can't move
forward
the concerning part is that even these
republicans who in michigan said there's
no fraud
um they have drafted a whole bunch of
voting restrictions
to fix the system that they claim has
glaring deficiencies when in reality
they are just voter suppression tactics
so
let's
you know things are more complicated
than black or white
it's good that even trump appointed
judges didn't allow this trash to move
forward it's a good thing that even the
michigan republican party said there's
no evidence of actual fraud here but
that very same republican party in
michigan is participating in some of
these more than 250 nationwide bills
to further restrict voting
so like most things in life it's not
exactly black and white
it is in a sense a victory that
republicans straight up said there's no
evidence of fraud but we still need to
be fighting them as far as we're
concerned when it comes to the voting
voter suppression that they are pushing
and republicans all over the country are
pushing but it shouldn't shock anybody
that a serious look at the allegations
in in all states but in this case in
michigan uh did not turn up any of the
fraud that they claim took place
we um have been following what has been
i mean at this point has it been seven
or eight different dates on which donald
trump was supposedly going to
be the winner of the 2020 election in
november it was by december this thing's
all going to be sorted out in december
it was definitely by january 20 by
january 6th it's going to be sorted out
after january 6th it was definitely by
january 20th then it became march
most recently it is august and one of
the big uh purveyors or perpetrators of
the completely bogus uh idea
that donald trump will be reinstated as
president in august is the my pillow ceo
mike lindell known to some as mike
pillow
donald trump has been reportedly pushing
this himself as reported by the new york
times washington post and national
review that he would be reinstated as
president in august
the constitution provides no mechanism
for such reinstatement it's impossible
if joe biden were unable to be president
for whatever reason it would go to the
vice president and subsequently the
speaker of the house you don't say let's
go back to the last guy
but
my pillow founder uh and ceo
mike lindell after weeks and weeks of
saying it will be august is now shifting
to say well it actually could be
september here he is yesterday on one
program now saying august september okay
we're going to see now do you believe
that trump will still be back in office
before long
yeah i think i've said august um now
with the timing i moved everything up
because i you know
support symposium and stuff and does
anybody know what symposium he's talking
about i'm not aware i don't even know
that he knows what symposium means never
mind there was one but okay and um
you know this i know that i know it's
gonna be you know they're gonna pull
this down they have to they won't have a
choice because of the evidence but
you know there's different things
they're doing i i've said august it
could be off by a month could be
september i believe it's going to be
this fall for sure i don't so now we've
got
it's it's august it could be september
but it'll definitely be the fall which
fall gets us until
i mean technically the winter doesn't
start until december 20th 20th or 21st
right so so now it's already getting
pushed and he's saying this on multiple
shows here's another one from the last
couple days they pulled this election
down and it's over you put our real
president back in by i think i think the
mainstream you go mike you said august
don't excuse me i might be out by a
month so there it is again he might be
off by just one month and as a reminder
don't forget
he was definitively saying august for a
really long time let's take a listen to
that what i'm talking about steve is
what i have been doing since january 9th
all the evidence i have everything is
going to go before the supreme court and
the election of 2020
is going bye-bye i it was an attack by
another country communism coming in i
don't know what they're going to do with
what after they pull it down but what's
he even talking about communism coming
in i don't even know what that means
hang on hang on something
donald trump
back in office in august
so that was even too wacky for steve
bannon that last clip was from steve
bannon's show and steve even saying oh
my god i got to control this guy slow
down here let me ask you more questions
and mike lindell would not be would not
be distracted so what's the reality of
what's going on here this is a grift
that's uh that's all it is it's a griff
for trump
um for mike lindell you know he
organized this rally a few weeks ago and
he's getting attention and and i guess
he sort of enjoys it um but this is
almost certainly going to become well
fall
um it's going to be early in 2022 and
then it's just going to be hey you know
what guys
we we we didn't get the supreme court to
do what we said they were going to do we
didn't get this other court we didn't
get this other court
we just have to vote now we just have to
vote and make sure that strong
supporters of donald trump win in
november of 22 that is what it will
become
we've been saying it for months at this
point in time and then it will become we
need to do this in order for trump 2024
and money will be raised and people will
spend money on this nonsense and they
will be bamboozled as they have been for
a really long time now
yesterday i we when i interviewed uh
psychiatrist
uh olok konoja
we talked about
what what is it for trump supporters
that has prevented them from getting
beyond the denial stage of grief
um and he said you know it's tough to
say as a group
i'd have to talk to them
individually
and
that was an astute answer and a logical
one because when these people call me
some of them are simply in denial about
the facts of what took place
whereas others don't focus as much on
bamboo fibers in arizona and massive
dumps in michigan or whatever the case
may be
and it's more about
the evils of joe biden and the sort of
the ends justify the means less about i
can't really articulate exactly how
biden stole it but biden's a communist
biden's a socialist biden's a marxist
and so it's justified to do whatever we
can do to put trump back in power even
if we can't really make the case that
the election was actually stolen um and
then i do think that for a non-zero
number it's also sort of like a mental
illness thing that that's going on
certainly some of the folks that have
called into my show at a very colloquial
level without diagnosing anybody they
don't seem in touch with reality and i
wouldn't be surprised if they have other
completely non-science-based conspiracy
theories about coveted vaccines would be
a top contender for sure
um but possibly in other areas as well
so it's not happening in august
it's not happening in september
it's not happening by the end of the
fall
and the start of winter
but they will smoothly transition into
we need to donate now so that friends of
trump can win in 2022 and impeach joe
biden and get trump back in that way
which won't happen which won't happen
that will get them to 2024
the 2024 campaign will probably start in
23
and that's going to be the next three
and a half years that seems to be very
clearly the direction that all of this
is going if you see it differently
i want to hear from you you can find me
on twitter at d pacman
we are going to hear from some of you
after this short break
and uh just a re you know for a friday
show this one is quite quite substantive
i must say we're probably going to save
the recording of this one we'll be back
right after this
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription when you go
to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember to grab yourself a membership
on our website
joinpacman.com the daily world famous
bonus show will be at your proverbial
and literal fingertips
if you become a member at joinpakman.com
let's hear from some folks in the
audience via discord you can join our
discord for free i'm selling you nothing
other than a free good time you can join
it at davidpakman.com
slash discord
we use the waiting lobby to do calls
why don't we go next to
jason from oahu is that in hawaii
i do can you hear me okay i can i think
the tubes must be narrow coming in from
hawaii because you sound a little bit uh
strange but i i'm curious how things are
going there
yeah things are great out here um i just
wanted to comment on your recent segment
on the right wing propaganda and the
architecture of it i thought it was
brilliant thank you
good question though what so in regards
to the specific topic that
carlson was talking about what do you
think like the implications or do you
think it's that far fetched to think
that there might be some kind of
subversion going on with the fbi we know
that there were proud boys and what was
the oath keepers that were there what
would be what would necessarily be the
the bad thing that he was saying um or
what he was implying with that segment
there's no evidence for it whatsoever so
as i said before you know some right
wingers now they love to say
by by the way are you brewing tea what
what is that noise
uh i'm actually i'm on my way to work oh
okay um so i'll meet my mic while you
speak sure yeah so so here's here's the
deal um
a lot of right-wingers now love to say
you stupid liberals
now all of you love the cia
you love the fbi you all think american
intelligence agencies can do no wrong
because of
uh their concern around trump and russia
and all of this different stuff that's
not the case whatsoever it's sort of
like with the lab leak covered stuff
uh i'm not against investigating
anything the problem is tucker did a
segment with no evidence where he went
in a three minute period from
these folks could be fbi agents to these
were fbi agents to the fbi organized the
trump riots all without evidence so
if anybody organized the riots i want to
know about it but we can't just shift
the narrative to this is what happened
without any actual evidence and so far
there's been no evidence presented
whatsoever we were aware of like an oath
keeper dude who was functioning as an
fbi informant that's a very different
thing than the fbi planned orchestrated
and perpetrated the the trump riots so
what the what tucker did wrong is that
he presented no evidence there's no
evidence for what he's saying
right no yeah i think uh and again that
was a brilliant way of pointing that out
and like showing your audience including
myself tools to recognize that i guess
um
i don't know it just seems uh to me that
it would have been easy to kind of
identify these things if the republicans
hadn't blocked the uh january 6th
commission
so that's another point that's another
point which is all of a sudden now
they're demanding investigations they
blocked the investigation and you're
you're completely right about
that hey thanks for taking my call my
pleasure my pleasure uh would love to
get to hawaii someday would love to get
there let's try
robin from our house
robin
can you hear me yes where is aarhus is
that australia
no that's in denmark denmark oh okay
beautiful
thanks for taking my call david i enjoy
your show very much pleasure it's very
very interesting
um i'm a
rather politically active myself in
denmark on the left wing and i follow
american politics with interest and your
show is very interesting to listen to
you thank you um uh i was i was just
wondering i'd love to hear your opinion
on something which is uh one thing i've
noticed very much in the american
political discourse is
sort of a lack of knowledge about what's
going on in the rest of the world um
like um it's and it seems to me to be a
problem on both sides of your political
spectrum over there um
obviously the right wing is totally
oblivious about what's going on in uh in
the rest of the world especially when
talking about things like
uh healthcare and the welfare state and
so on um
we generally laugh at them very much
over here i'm sorry to say
um but i've also noticed it um
sometimes on the left um
where we sometimes have this sort of
feeling that
like like let me give you an example
when when when you when uh you finally
legalized gay marriage in america there
was like huge demonstrations like this
but this is going to be great for the
whole world and we're right we've had
this for decades
over here it's like it's not this isn't
it
yeah and um to some degree i mean listen
i'm guilty of this myself to some degree
you know i do a show mostly on american
politics and that limits the amount of
time that i spend following the politics
of other countries other than argentina
because i'm from there and so i follow
the politics there somewhat closely but
for example you know should i be more
informed about what's happening in
ethiopia right now absolutely you know i
have i have a sense of what's going on
and i've read a few articles but i
should be more informed should i be more
informed about what's happening in the
congo right now um
yeah there's no question about it and i
think that
there's one aspect of it that i think is
important to recognize which is it is
natural that the world will follow the
news more of countries that are setting
some of the cultural
uh
lines of sort of like global culture and
in that sense technologically and
culturally the us is very important it's
not singularly important so to some
degree it's logical and also because of
the size of the us i understand why for
example
folks in denmark are probably better
informed about american politics than
americans about danish politics like to
a degree that makes sense but i agree
with you that americans are
under-informed uh globally for sure
yeah
and just
my point is mainly just that it would be
healthy because i believe that for
example most danish people obviously not
all because we've got loads of different
different political opinions here as
well but most danish people would be
able to say with a certain extent of
accuracy
what most other countries think of
denmark for example ah
but i don't get that feeling from
americans i don't get the feeling that
you like if i were to ask an american
what do you think would you what do you
think this what do you think that
generally the idea of units is in spain
for example
i don't think most americans would
really know
well
there's a couple different there's a
couple different things there i mean
number one
global opinion of the us
was very low during the trump era other
than russia
i believe turkey
and there was one african country i
forget which which had sort of like an
unusually high
favorability but most of the world was
pretty disgusted with the us under trump
much of that reputation has recovered
under biden and so part of it there's a
there's two things there one is
depending on who's president we elect
sometimes such wacky people that opinion
of the u.s changes drastically up and
down around the world the second piece
of it is there's lots of republicans who
don't want to accept the reality
of global opinion of the us and so they
whether they know or don't know they
certainly don't want to accept it
no that's that's true but it was very
interesting to get your opinion that
thank you very much uh for taking my
call david my pleasure so are you where
in denmark do you live is it possible to
ask well uh always is the second largest
uh city in denmark it's on the eastern
coast of jutland
wow i've never been to that region i
have only been to copenhagen and some
immediately surrounding areas
loved it absolutely loved it and in fact
when i was bicycling in copenhagen
a viewer of mine stopped me on the bike
path and said i watch you from denmark
and we took a picture together it's on
my instagram
yeah i know i know several people who
know you i mean yeah it's very
interesting watching you you're you have
a very sort of uh
it's a very objective uh
you have a very nice object it doesn't
seem like you're preaching which is we
appreciate that in denmark i i
appreciate your appreciation of it
yes thank you thank you very much i
appreciate it yeah take care very very
interesting call yeah loving it
absolutely loving hearing from some of
these folks
let's go next to
how about zach from west virginia what's
happening in west virginia with joe
manchin hey what's going on dave how are
you can you hear me i can't i can you're
coming through pristine today
oh wonderful yeah
um so
my main question was i actually had two
questions that's fine
one is
is it's kind of a vague question
it's uh how just how historical do you
think the moment we're living in
like this decade
in particular is
i have no idea whatsoever and that's one
of those things where you know i could
give you some hot take on it it would
just be a guess i i really don't know we
don't know that until we look back and
and kind of have more context uh i think
that
there's the potential for this decade as
an important inflection moment because
in 2016 the u.s elected trump and we saw
this slide globally to authoritarianism
we now we may be getting out of that
or we may not and so i do think over the
next 10 years we're going to see
what are the following 50 maybe going to
look like in terms of whether this
authoritarianism and right-wing
nationalism takes hold or it's rejected
but to say
exactly the level of importance of this
decade i think it's we're really just
guessing
yeah that's exactly what i what i
thought as well um
but anyways my second question was uh
please i noticed you sang on your show a
couple times that you played drums in a
band now is there any video of this band
playing that i i
that we could see that's a good question
uh there there may be uh if you went so
the i'm not in a band currently but the
last band i was in was a band called tin
fingers not ten but tin like the tin man
from the wizard of oz
and i think it's plausible
plausible
that there are videos from what some of
our performances in the brooklyn area on
youtube i'm not sure
all right well i'll have to go i'm on a
deep dive for that all right please
absolutely yeah now we've we had some
great great material
all right dave this isn't the first time
i'm gonna call but i'll let you go you
mean this isn't the last time you mean
oh yeah yeah yeah for sure it is the
first time but it won't be the last time
all right very good all right thank you
so much great call from west virginia
beautiful audio i mean whatever they're
doing in west virginia infrastructure
wise big picture
it sounds bad but that call was a
beautiful beautiful call let's take a
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up because i'm going right back to
discord davidpakman.com discord and
we'll hear from a few more people in a
moment
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back ground news is
one of the first things i would use to
get my head in the game and prepare
myself for the interview because ground
news is a news source comparison
platform that lets you compare how
outlets from the left right and center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story and it also shows you
your news blind spots stories that your
side of the political spectrum may not
have covered ground news can help you
build a well-crafted argument for
debating people you disagree with or
ground news can help you discover
something new about your own perspective
challenging your own strongly held views
on political issues be the most informed
person in the room download the free
ground news app today by going to
dot news slash pacman
okay let's hear from a few more people
today a real mix of calls you can join
via discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go back to mobile
alabama and try again mobile are you is
are things functioning
yeah hey david can you hear me i can
i apologize last time i had the wrong
keyboard push to talk apology accepted
my question to you is um have you ever
lived in an area that wasn't necessarily
a liberal leaning area and if you
have or if you haven't how do you
how do you suggest people who maybe are
more on the liberal side
uh cope with living in an area where the
vast majority of people do not share
maybe even like 60 of your views right
yeah so i've not permanently lived in
such an area but i've spent
you know cumulatively months and months
in such areas typically you know a
couple of weeks at a time
my recommendation is
find a community that does match up more
with your views so
you know at one point in one place i
found that there was kind of like a
a left-leaning non-super religious
jewish community group and i met some
interesting people with that who mostly
shared my views through the um living
liberally organization a lot of places
will have you know like a drinking
liberally chapter or
that type of thing um so so the way i
would cope with it would be to just eat
you know even if you're in a place that
might be 65 35
conservative like you know utah is
really really conservative in salt lake
city and i think in provo there are
still a bunch of liberal people and
liberal groups that you can kind of make
your community so i i think that that
would be my approach i mean in a really
rural area it could be very popular in
rural idaho or something like that i
don't know whether this is even feasible
but in most larger towns and smaller
cities there's a population there that
will be aligned with you yeah i'm from
northwest florida and this area of
alabama and it seems like a huge portion
of the population just lives in a
different reality in some cases and and
my question to further to go further is
how do you see and do you see any path
for a progressive kind of uh thought
to permeate these areas and and grow or
ever take hold you know i really it's
funny you you mentioned northwest
florida because we have a bunch of great
friends in northwest florida um in
pensacola associated with the entire
ring of fire you know ring of fire
productions and mike antonio farron
cousins and that entire team is in
northwest uh northwest florida um and so
i've been down i've been down there and
it's a it's a red area
but even pensacola has these blue
enclaves now part of it is it's a big
it's a big sort of a legal area for mass
torts and mass torts lawyers tend to
lean left so that's kind of like a
predetermined community there but even
there there's you know you got your
hipster cafes and you've got your stuff
i mean it really is spreading
it's it's helpful to think of it in that
way i just wonder if we'll
ever see the policy uh dictated by our
local leaders well that's going to
depend on getting activated and voting
that's a different question that's less
of a cultural question and it's more of
a
voting question yeah but i mean i hope
so
thank you david my pleasure all right
mobile alabama great glad to be able to
put that together
let's go
next to
let's go to veronica
hello
hello david can you hear me
yes i can
hi david i just had one question
i wanted to ask you do you think that
the vaccination rate is accurate because
i know that the us is vaccinating like a
lot of tourists and people from abroad
and do you think that that affects like
the vaccination rate of the citizens
here
veronica are you from argentina
no i'm not you are where are you from
mermaid weather from ecuador okay um
yeah so okay very good question there
are places now like in florida
where tourists can get vaccinated
and then there's a real question as to
whether they're being reported as an
american vaccination or not so you're
completely right that the number is
going to be off slightly because of
foreigners that are getting vaccinated
but it's a relatively small number so i
don't think it's off by very much
yeah i know they are being reported as
americans because because my family has
been here and they got vaccinated and
they didn't even ask them like right are
you from here
okay i have another question sure
i live in mississippi okay wow
you know this is a red state yeah so
i think that yesterday dr jill biden
came here like for the vaccination thing
that
joe biden was doing yeah to promote
vaccination
and do you think that that's
the really has an effect because i think
the people here if they haven't got
their vaccine already they are not going
to change their mind i think that it's
not going to move the numbers
significantly but i think it will make a
little bit of a difference is it enough
to change our path to herd immunity i
don't know but i still think every
little bit helps
okay
thank you david veronica where in
ecuador are you from
ah and now quito is quite uh elevated
right is it 12 000 feet
yes i think it is are you completely
used to the elevation if you go back to
visit or does it take you time to adjust
i am you said you are even living in the
low lands of mississippi your body still
is ready for the elevation
yeah i went there like three months ago
and i was it was completely fine really
yeah okay all right good news
thank you david okay thanks veronica
veronica from ecuador great call unclear
what was happening in the background i
know
but uh i found the call generally
riveting so i thought i'd just let it
slide let's go next to quinn from dallas
texas quinn you're on the air oh hello
david
thanks for taking calls on discord this
is my first time calling in my pleasure
yeah absolutely i actually wanted to ask
you uh one thing so i'm a little younger
i'm a freshman in college right um and i
was wondering kind of about the
messaging that we have um as liberals
left us progressives whatever you want
to call us yeah um i share a lot of the
same views as my friends that are
further left than me but i find that a
lot of my like peers in college are only
on the right because they disagree with
the further left which obviously they
hear more about
um so do you think it's going to be like
more beneficial like in the future for i
mean politicians
um and then just people in general to
kind of um stick to i guess a more
um in between what we have in office and
then like promoting socialism that kind
of thing somewhere in between those two
well even even those as the as the lines
are arbitrary and probably not
necessarily
accurate i mean it's why would you say
that it should be between those two
poles
so for me personally i have a lot of
interaction where uh what happens is the
only reason i have lots of my classmates
disagree um in terms of their political
like efficacy when they're trying to
convince people of things um is because
they say oh well you on the left want to
get rid of like our entire structural
system um and then they go into the
whole i mean anti-trans anti whatever
immigration that kind of thing so taking
the most extreme positions and then um
garnering those is the ones that um i
guess most progressives hold i think a
better approach a better approach than
than maybe
creating some new arbitrary middle
between two extremes or two two places
on the political spectrum that may not
even accurately reflect
the vast majority of the population it
would be more interesting just to
immediately correct when people start
arguing against some far left socialist
view of what the left wants to
immediately say there are very few
actual socialists in the united states
and even fewer actual socialists in
position of power can you tell me which
elected official wants that which
elected official says that the means of
production should be seized which
elected officials at the federal level
are actual socialists put it back on
them and because there aren't any uh or
almost any if you look at city councils
and stuff like that they would be unable
to i think that that's a better approach
absolutely yeah that helps a lot i think
definitely because in a lot of cases
what you're seeing now is there's so
much overlap in the general consensus on
policy positions yeah um and it's it's
genuinely just the identity of what side
you fall on that kind of is determining
how people were voting um and then i i
guess i had one more question so i'm
really interested in moving abroad right
i've always wanted to move to germany
because i've been learning german for
the past three years um and my question
is what do you think is kind of the best
method for americans who really do care
about the direction of the country um
when it comes to kind of promoting their
views or their i don't want to say
agenda but from i guess a foreign
perspective
you're saying if you went to germany
what could you best do to promote your
view of american politics absolutely
exactly because i feel like when i move
i'm kind of i don't want to say
abandoning but leaving um you know
a part of my country in the sense that i
won't be able to have the same change
it's kind of okay um there are problems
we have here and that's kind of why i do
want to move so i feel like i'm
abandoning those problems and just
running away from them because they're
hard to deal with i mean listen you you
kind of are i hate to say it but the
best the best way to achieve change in
the united states is to stay in the
united states and
fight for it i mean with social media
and digital activism you can be in
germany you could be phone banking more
than anybody in the u.s is right so
i think there are things that you can do
but i think it's important to recognize
like moving to germany is not how you
achieve change in the united states it's
totally fine for you to move to germany
i have no problem with you doing it and
yeah at a certain point saying i've had
enough and i'm bailing i i it's you know
ultimately we've got to live our lives i
think i'm i'm not attacking that but i
think you in a sense you're going to be
much better able to achieve change in
the u.s if you're in the u.s than if
you're in germany
yeah you're absolutely right and also
that would completely tank your chances
of running later because they would say
oh you left the country you don't really
you know that yeah to some degree that
may be true if your plan is to get into
politics personally yeah but listen i
think it sounds like it'll be
fascinating to be in germany for a
period i'm going to be in germany
actually in august myself
that's so cool well i hope you enjoy
your dime there i definitely will be
calling it again so thanks for taking my
call yeah all right my pleasure thanks
very much quinn
um very nice caller
all right let's go next to where do we
want to go next
how about um
what about sid from ohio sid you're on
the air
and you're watching your show
um yeah i was wondering what do you
think about the uh the right the left
alt media like young turks and some
other news it seems like they spread a
lot of
times like if not conspiracy false news
and i know that the the right like fox
and you had some like breitbart they do
it on purpose what do you think do you
think the left also does it on purpose
what fake news did the young turks
spread
well the young turk they constantly
promote like bernie sanders as the it
which we know he if he would have won
that probably would not have been great
for left you know like like they focus
on like ocasio-cortez they focus on
certain candidates and almost like run a
promotional
um
you know promotional thing for him like
but how is that
how is that fake news
well they're not they're not being fair
to the watchers to like really give them
like a good idea of who these candidates
are they focus on certain policies like
like specifically like the one fake news
i do remember
is um um one of the the popular girl
she during a debate was talking about um
hold on
like let's just back up just a little
bit
okay okay who the popular girl what are
you saying
sorry i don't remember her name but
she's one of the main um
you're saying one of the hosts of the
young turks are you talking about anna
yes
yes anna yeah yeah that's okay okay okay
so so anna was in a debate with uh tommy
lahren and i was watching and uh she
said that how the
unemployment rate in america even though
it went down during trump it it actually
went up for
qualified um like like people who have a
college degree but actually we're
working like minimum wage jobs so it
actually fell
and i when i checked the facts on that
that was wrong that did not happen now
that was that politicon right that was
that politicon
okay so i don't know the statistic but
if anna said it something that was wrong
that's not fake news that sounds like
she was mistaken fake news would be like
if i say hillary clinton
gave birth to an alien baby like that
would be fake news being wrong about an
unemployment rate isn't fake news and it
also wasn't on the young turks it sounds
like it was in the middle of a debate
right right
right but it just seems like that the
vibe that i get from young turks like
they're heavily heavily biased like you
don't seem like you're like like when i
listen to you you seem like somebody
who's reporting objective journalism
listen
i i think i'm as biased as the young
we're all doing opinion shows okay so i
think that this is a media literature
we're all doing opinion shows it's
possible that what you're saying is
your opinions differ from those on the
young turks where like the young turks
was too pro bernie for you
or too pro aoc for you
but um i i don't think it we're all
doing opinion programs so i'm i would
recalibrate your critique maybe maybe
what you mean is you don't agree
politically with the young turks is that
maybe what you're saying
um
i feel like i feel like they don't
like like here's the thing like if you
watch fox like
they might like like i'm not i'm a
democrat myself but i feel like if you
watch fox like you might get a better
highlight of um
of what the the representative like like
the downfalls of certain certain
representatives are like we can go down
the list of bernie and aoc and and how
their support might support some of the
wrong things but you're not going to
hear that on on the young terms like
they will they will only say good things
about them okay i don't know whether
that's true or not because i don't i
don't watch any of these shows you know
on my program i at least try to give you
like for example when i talk about
medicare for all
i say
medicare for all could be a great way to
organize health care here's all the
great things about it here's some that
are question marks and here's three
other ways we could organize healthcare
like i'm making that effort the counter
though would be do you think you heard
about the downsides of donald trump on
fox news
um
there are a few um demo it feels like
democratic like the guy who hosted the
debate like he would be like hard on it
the other guy who quit fox he was also
like going hard on him but yeah they're
very few who say right yeah so i think
the the issue here is
the young turks and my show and sam
cedars show
we
are opinion programs and we don't hide
that the problem on fox is they present
opinion as if it's news and that's a
real problem so that's why i think your
example is a false equivalency
oh well i i thought that when the fox
when they got sued uh they they said
that their piece is an opinion piece
that's the thing they had that that's
not a reliable news because right that's
that's that's a legal defense that they
use but
what fox is notorious for doing is
deliberately blurring the lines between
what is news and news and opinion this
is a big conversation about media
literacy i think it's really great that
you're thinking about these things i
think maybe
if if you had maybe a slightly more
sophisticated understanding of some of
these media literacy issues your
analysis would be even better i think is
the way i would put a positive spin on
it
okay all right
all right my friend thank you for the
call i mean listen it's great that
people are even he
he's misinformed about the facts and
lacks some understanding but the fact
that he's thinking about this stuff is
more than can be said for a lot of
people um that's uh that that's for sure
all right thanks everybody i really
appreciate everybody who called in today
we're out of time for today but we will
take more calls again in the future and
we're going to be right back with more
show right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right let's get right into audience
questions for the week really good
questions this week first one david
should naturalized american citizens be
allowed to run for president and be
president in the united states i think
the answer is obviously yes you know the
origin of banning naturalized immigrants
from running for president
was really based around the idea of some
kind of subterfuge of a traitorous or
disloyal individual becoming president
and really being loyal to some other
country
etc and the the practical reality is
that in the modern day
there's no reason to believe number one
that we wouldn't
determine
um that there would be
a problem with someone's loyalties
through the course of a presidential
campaign because it is so invasive and
so extensive and goes on for such a
period of time number two
the reality is that the country is based
on immigrants who came here because they
wanted something different than what was
going on in england and in other places
and to say
that if you've gone through the process
you've come here legally you've obtained
permanent residency you then qualify for
citizenship and you are now a citizen
to say well yeah you're a citizen but
you can't run for president it is in a
sense creating a second tier of
citizenship now you could make the case
and i might be swayed by it
that
naturalized citizens should be allowed
to be president but they must be
citizens for a period of time before
they can be sworn in as president so if
you became
a citizen today
maybe some number of years have to go by
i think that's a good question i'd be
open to being convinced of that as an
additional requirement
but the truth is that many of the
immigrants that are naturalized in the
u.s
by more decent and sensible standards of
what we really should aspire to mean by
patriotism many immigrants are far more
patriotic in in a way that the term
makes sense
than americans who just happen to be
born in the united states
further
actually passing the citizenship test
already confers more of an understanding
of how the us is supposed to work than
many natural-born american citizens have
so i think that it should be changed
it's not for me i don't plan to run for
president uh even if it's changed i'm
not interested in running for president
and i know many will write to me and
they'll say david of course you want it
changed it's what's preventing you from
running for president i have no plan in
uh to to run for president but
uh consider the history of this country
understand the basis on which this
country was formed
uh and realize that the sort of two
tiers of citizenship really don't make
sense and um the the arguments that i
continue to hear against
naturalized citizens being able to be
president
leverage and depend on fear-mongering
they defend depend on nationalistic
rhetoric
they depend often on xenophobic ideas
they want to stoke fear
but
most people understand that immigrants
to the united states who go through the
process of becoming citizens are by the
definition of patriotism we should
aspire to
just as patriotic as anybody else and
really do want what's best for the
country now just one other reminder
just because naturalized immigrants
could be allowed to be president
doesn't mean they would win
in a huge part of this country
a naturalized citizen even if allowed to
run
would have no shot whatsoever because of
all the things i just mentioned how it
would be used to stoke fear and leverage
nationalism and on and on and on so
let them run
let them be president if they win
legally i still think you would see a
huge uphill battle in many parts of the
united states
hey david is critical race theory
actually dangerous like right winger say
or is it just kind of reductive yeah
this is good you know the
i've issued many critiques about
critical race theory on this show
i don't think it's dangerous um i think
as a general concept one can always
argue being uninformed can have negative
consequences and so you could say well
if you believe that no matter how fast
you drive you won't get hurt if you get
into a car crash yeah that's a belief
that's dangerous in a very specific and
tangible way when it comes to critical
race theory
i wouldn't apply the word dangerous i i
do think however
that um
critical race theory could potentially
be harmful to race relations between
individuals that's number one
i do think critical race theory is
reductive
in the way that it deals with
race over
many other factors that affect how
people relate to each other in modern
society
um and i've i've talked before about how
you know critical theories like critical
race theory
heavily are supported by ideas of
post-modernism and post-structuralism
and this is not me going all jordan
peterson talking about
post-modernism and that that's not it's
not this vague critique and i'm not
saying uh anything beyond what i'm
actually saying
but
the basis of critical race theory and
the genesis of some of the ideology and
post-modernism and post-structuralism
relies on
um
the ideas
in some combination
that reality is socially constructed
it's it's sort of an attack on
empiricism and it's a propping up of the
idea that
any reality any notion any analysis
could be just as real as any other
and in some cases taken to a very you
know extreme place
uh could be
deserves equal footing
in discussions about how society should
be organized um and then one of the
other aspects of critical race theory
that i think is very problematic now by
by the way if you're going to email me
you're going to say david that one piece
doesn't apply to all of critical race
theory fine i'm i'm talking in
generalities about things that exist
within uh enclaves of critical race
theory
one of the really concerning things i
see
are
very very um casual
claims
levied against anyone who challenges
aspects of critical race theory that
merely by challenging critical race
theory you are a white supremacist
you are racist
you are an oppressor you were part of
the problem we saw this earlier this
week with the story about the seattle
pride event some pride event in seattle
that was only going to charge a fee to
white people how do you identify which
those people are i don't know
and they weren't calling it an admission
fee they were calling it a reparations
fee to get around saying
the admission is is
depending on race
um and then when some members of the
seattle city council said this this this
is bad this really doesn't make any
sense
they were accused of doing violence by
critiquing the plan of only charging the
reparations fee to the white attendees
that's a that's a non-starter for me
that's the opposite of rational inquiry
and uh so back to the question is
critical race theory actually dangerous
i think just about any idea if taken far
enough you could justify and say it
would be dangerous in this way
uh i think that it's incomplete i think
it's reductive and i think it's
counterproductive over the long term uh
to both race relations and achieving
real equality under the law and and in
society
which i think is an important add-on
because many areas we have equality
under the law
but for sociocultural reasons we don't
have actual equality that's my sense let
me know your thoughts david how can
democrats better appeal to rural voters
so
i don't know if this will be seen as
controversial by people in my audience
but a lot of democratic rhetoric on gun
control is completely counterproductive
i am probably right there with
95 percent of the policy
that many democratic lawmakers want on
gun safety
but
every time that democrats uh campaign on
gun control
number one many sound very uninformed
very very uninformed it's like do they
do they even understand how guns work
and that's a real problem for a huge
part of this country including rural
folks who remember
rural folks relationship to guns is very
different than that of people who live
in cities and suburbs and other places
number two
i think that the focus needs to better
emphasize economic issues
in a way that relates to working class
maybe
better than
sort of like uh
tech millennials and i think that
sometimes the economic
rhetoric of democrats
works pretty well for young people and
people working in white-collar jobs but
who are just not paid that well or with
a lot of student debt
but often is not
rhetoric and language
that's well tuned
to more rural folks and this includes
farmers this includes factory workers
and and you know just every once in a
while talking about unions
there's lots of rural folks who have one
local employer where you drive 40 miles
to a factory where we might think being
on the left they should love to hear
about how we support unionization
look at what happened in alabama with
amazon where they voted against
unionizing now of course there was a
huge propaganda war and it's a much more
complicated thing but having spoken to
people who work in factories in the
midwest and in other places
just talking about unions is not going
to do it for democrats so i think that
it's sort of a three-pronged approach i
think the rhetoric around gun control
around elections has to be either
dropped or fixed it doesn't mean you
stop working on the issues it just means
you you stop campaigning so aggressively
on that because it turns a lot of those
rural folks off number two you figure
out how to better talk to farmers and
agricultural
employers and workers
and
number three
you tweak the economic message
to not be so union heavy but more about
understanding the plight of a lot of
these economically ravaged areas
where whether the one employer is
unionized or not and i support the
unionization
that's not a path to fixing or dealing
with
the way that the area has been ravaged
big picture
overwhelmingly by the republican sort of
supply side policies that came out of
the 1980s those would be my three kind
of bits of advice for democrats to
better appeal to rural voters and the
truth is that appealing to rural voters
in california
versus mississippi
are certainly two different things and
and the midwest as a third one those are
my initial thoughts let me know what you
think we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today get instant access by becoming
a member at joinpackman.com see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman ground news is combating
divisiveness in media ground is a news
comparison platform that helps you see
multiple perspectives for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader download the free app at
ground dot news slash pacman